Вакуумні бомби, реактивна артилерія та найелітніші сухопутні сили Росії, 1-ша гвардійська танкова армія.
Ось деякі з видів зброї та військових частин, які ще не були задіяні під час вторгнення в Україну,
констатує Мейсон Кларк, провідний аналітик щодо Росії в Інституті вивчення війни у Вашингтоні.
Чесно кажучи, це просто диво, що вони дозволили ВПС України залишатися в бойовій готовності
вісім днів після початку війни, хоча теоретично мала бути можливість "приземлити" їх на самому початку операції.
А вежі стільникового зв'язку, припускає американський аналітик,
Кремль досі не вивів з ладу лише через те, що президент Путін хотів би зберегти можливість
доносити кремлівські пропагандистські меседжі українцям.
Ми вважаємо, саме тому вони продовжують у різний спосіб доносити інформацію до українського народу
замість того, щоб відверто блокувати Україну за допомогою кібератак та інших засобів.
У свою чергу інший аналітик, Александер Віндман, колишній співробітник Ради безпеки США,
вважає, що ситуація перших днів війни показує, що Путін неабияк прорахувався, недооцінивши український опір.
І його план "Б", спрямований, як багато хто вважає, на масштабні удари по цивільних об'єктах,
може підірвати моральний дух російських солдатів.
Насправді це найгірший сценарій для російських наземних військ, тому що вони увійшли до міст.
Російські військові виходили з того, що вони - миротворці,
що їм не доведеться вести затяжні бої з українцями.
Вони очікували, що під'їдуть до міст і їх привітно зустрінуть, а зіштовхнулися із запеклим опором.
І це удар по свідомості солдата, коли він чекає на одне, а отримує прямо протилежне.
Віндман прогнозує, що Путін рано чи пізно зіткнеться зі зростаючим тиском усередині Росії,
насамперед через кількість жертв та наслідки економічних санкцій.
Досі не відбувалося соціально-економічних протестів.
Але вони виникнуть, коли пройдуть тижні під санкціями, коли силовики не зможуть отримувати зарплати,
коли люди не зможуть заправляти свої автомобілі тощо.
І це додасть проблем Путіну, і йому доведеться на це реагувати.
А потім з війни почнуть надходити тисячі трун із трупами солдатів.
Кількість жертв величезна. Це буде основним фактором, що дестабілізує.
Тож, зрештою йому доведеться міняти плани військових операцій.
Подальший перебіг подій значною мірою залежить також від того,
чи будуть країни НАТО з тих чи інших причин напряму втягнуті у війну Росії проти України.
Якщо Україна впаде, якщо Росія почне насаджувати там маріонетковий режим,
якщо Росія почне вдаватися до репресій проти українського населення,
яке, ймовірно, не буде визнавати цей маріонетковий уряд,
тоді ситуація справді стане жахливою.
Тому що з того наративу, який Путін поширює в останні дні і впродовж останніх 20 років,
будь-хто, хто проти Путіна на територіях, які, як він думає, належать йому,
негайно розцінюються ним як якісь агенти ЦРУ або підбурені Заходом.
Тобто якщо Україна програє, він, звісно, робитиме нас, Захід, відповідальними за все погане, що там коїтиметься.
І, можливо, вдасться до військової сили або військових засобів, щоб - я би взяв це у лапки,
бо це лише черговий наратив Путіна - "ми відмовилися від втручання у його внутрішні справи".
Але поки Україна бореться, поки вона чинить спротив, поки українська держава функціонує,
Росія зайнята тим, щоб зруйнувати все це.
На думку американського аналітика Віндмана, найімовірнішим є такий сценарій:
після затяжної війни з великими втратами російські війська відступлять,
а Путін оголосить про свою перемогу.
Але збитки, завдані йому як усередині країни, так і на зовнішній арені
через рішення вторгнутися в Україну, можуть наблизити кінець режиму Путіна.
Я думаю, що це початок кінця Путіна.
Я не говорю, що це закінчиться переворотом.
Я не кажу, що на нього вчинять замах люди з його оточення.
І не говорю про те, що це переросте в масові протести, які скинуть уряд.
Таке прогнозувати важко.
Але те, як події розгорталися досі, безперечно, вказує на початок кінця Путіна.
Американський аналітик робить висновок, що щонайменше перспектива
перебування Путіна при владі до 2036 року тепер - уже в минулому.